Wonder Woman is directed by patty
Jenkins the director of monster and
stars gal gadot as Diana Prince
the film shows us her origins as she
trained to become a warrior and
eventually she meets Chris Pine
a man who washes up on shore at her
homeland and a man is very rare around
those parts and she then learns of World
War 1 and wants to help and take part
and battle against the German and I went
to this screening really excited but at
the same time realistic I want to be a
little reserved and I don't like to get
my hopes up because disappointment
always sucks especially with big movies
I'm excited for and the DC movie since
Man of Steel haven't impressed me that
much I haven't yet seen a great one one
that I want to watch over and over and
over that's a breath I've been holding
since 2013 Wonder Woman is the first
really really legitimately good DC EU
movie despite all of the hate that went
her way when she got cast gal gadot owns
the role of Wonder Woman she reminded me
of Christopher Reeve in the first
Superman movie full of joy hope and
completely without cynicism this is a
fantastic casting choice she really
nailed this role this movie was a total
blast from start to finish it has a lot
of the things that I want to see in a
superhero movie it's extremely funny
Chris Pine has amazing chemistry with
gal gadot and there's two
fish-out-of-water stories in this movie
the first act is Chris Pine in this
place and he's like I don't get any of
this and everything is surprising to him
and he's learning a lot about Diana and
her upbringing and then we have another
fish out of the water story and that's
Diana going away from her homeland and
learning about the real world and what's
going on there and world war one and so
we get to see two characters who sort of
teach each other things which I was
really happy about because I didn't want
to just go to this movie and see a
perfect character with no flaws from the
very beginning she has a lot to learn
she's very naive and the film was wise
to understand that and it allows you to
go on this journey with her and feel
like you're experiencing all of her ups
and downs emotionally it's not just like
she's born she's a perfect fighter she's
a superhero nobody can touch her she's
not a Mary Sue that term that describes
someone who's just perfect at everything
a lot of people complain about ray in
the force awakens
that this very self-sufficient character
that had virtually no flaws that's very
much so not the case
in Wonder Woman this isn't just about
empowerment like this perfect person who
hates men and doesn't like men and men
suck it's actually a very equal movie
which is something I was really excited
about because I really didn't want to
watch another Ghostbusters movie where
the entire time I'm just reminded about
how horrible I am because I'm a man this
actually it's very much so the opposite
of that which brings me to Chris Pine
their chemistry is amazing they both
learn from each other and their
relationship in the film went to
emotional Heights that I did not expect
and I was genuinely touched by the end
of the film I was really into that
aspect of the movie which was a major
surprise and I found myself really
caring but he brings a lot to the movie
he's not just some guy that she's
constantly saving because he's some weak
guy like he actually brings quite a bit
to her character and her to him they
both really learn from each other and
there's a lot of times in the movie
where patty Jenkins and the screenwriter
they took the time to have smaller
moments there's a scene where he teaches
her how to dance and it really means a
lot for their characters but it's also
the type of quiet small moment you don't
normally get in movies like this and it
makes their relationship so much more
fleshed out and there's a lot of scenes
like that I won't get into any spoilers
but there's a lot of times where the
movie does slow down and lets these
characters just be people it's not just
a mindless series of action scenes
there's quite a bit of action in it and
when the action is going down my god
it's satisfying there's a lot of tiny
action moments but there's like three
major set pieces in each act there's an
incredible sequence on her homeland an
amazing world war one sequence and of
course the big epic finale that finale
did get a little CGI heavy and it
reminded me of some of the doomsday
stuff in the end of VBS for some people
that might be a turn-off but here I
thought it was handled considerably
better in regards to the way it was all
cut together there is a lot of CGI and
that's to be expected because Wonder
Woman is not normal
so that kind of shit's going to happen
but since I actually cared about the
characters this time around I didn't
mind as much when it got CGI heavy my
biggest gripe with Wonder Woman is
pretty much the same one I've had with
most superhero movies as of late whether
it's Marvel or DC and that's the villain
characters they're pretty weak there's
like two or three in this movie and some
of them are just so poorly
underdeveloped and they feel very hammy
which doesn't really fit in with the
rest of the movie and that was a major
disappointment for me the movie is
really long but I think it works for
this character you really needed to see
her upbringing her roots where she came
from why she is the way she is it wasn't
just a bunch of padded scenes and they
also wisely understood which elements of
her origin to poke fun at which things
sounded silly enough to make a joke out
of it and so it wasn't just it was kind
of like the way they did it with for
like Thor has some really silly and
cheesy origins and they found ways to
poke fun at it and make it entertaining
enough so that you could at least get a
joke out of it I talked about it briefly
but some of the action scenes are
genuinely epic like the very definition
of epic the score is also really
exciting and I'm looking forward to
buying it all in all Wonder Woman is
pretty much exactly what I would want
out of a Wonder Woman movie I am so
happy to say that this is the first
great DC EU movie and I had a blast with
it the villain characters could be
better this isn't like the best DC movie
since the Dark Knight I would say The
Dark Knight Rises is probably still a
better film but this is a blast it's
really fun
also colorful this is a really colorful
movie it's not be saturated and
depressing there's a ton of colors in
almost every scene which oh my god just
colors people they really matter I'm
going to give Wonder Woman an A - I
really did have a blast with this one
guys and I hope you do too I also met a
lot of really great fans at this
screening and I want to give them a nice
shout out it was so cool to meet you
guys Matt Angelique Camille Josh and
Andrew I always love meeting you guys so
if you ever see me at a movie just come
up and say hi I'd love to meet you thank
you so much as always for watching guys
are the best and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck my
knives
[Music]